hey reason TV viewers I'm Andrew  Campanella president of national school  choice week and national school choice  week begins in just days here's what  national school choice week 2013 will  look like there's a huge kick off  celebration in Phoenix Arizona featuring  the Jonas Brothers we're doing a  whistle-stop train tour from Los Angeles  to New York with 14 important events  along the way and there are 3500 a  record-breaking 3500 individually  planned events spanning all 50 states  but what matters most is what you're  doing for national school choice week so  consider planning an event no event is  too small and everyone can make a  difference I want you to check back at  reason.com for exclusive coverage of  national school choice week and also  visit school choice week com  you